Well,
the first step,
the reason why I use the East West
paradigm is because the West has
dominated world history for 200 years
and that's been the prevailing narrative
for 200 years.
That narrative is coming to an end.
So it's important to emphasize that
that's the one night is coming to an end
now the Eco,
right?
It's absolutely diverse.
She's remarkably diverse.
I mean,
China and India you mentioned are very
different,
but what most western minds don't
realize is that in previous centuries
there were a lot of connections among
the Asian countries.
Fairly deep connection.
To illustrate this with my Mike Best of
case,
now I'm ethnically cindy.
Cindy is a province in Pakistan and my
religion,
I was born a Hindu.
Okay.
Yet when I grew up,
the script that I learned to write with
as a Hindu,
the right cindy is the Arabic script and
it shows the connection,
the Hindu,
Cindy's halfway the Islamic world,
you know,
in Arab,
in,
in the Arab world and in pressure.
And at the same time when I traveled to
the East Asia,
when I go to Japan,
when I go to Korea,
when I go to China,
I still feel a sense of cultural
affinity because I can,
I feel like an understand the Buddhist
cultures that revealing those societies
because what does it came from India and
I had some Buddhists influence,
uh,
in my life too as a child.
So,
you know,
you can see that in my personal case,
if I can personally feel connected with
West Asia.
Okay.
If you personally connected with East
Asia,
that's an illustration of how Aisha
comes together in many ways that is not
understood by the West.
Okay.